try to be as inconspicuous as possible
yeah one person working here if this
person would just scoot over would you
mind sir
sir Ann said she didn't mind all the
practical jokes who you would play with
her unset because she's such a huge fan
of yours what tell me about some of your
favorite ones you did to her I did
because I improvised quite a bit in the
movie and I would improvise a lot of
insults just to my face
I also very inappropriately touched her
in one take when I should have told her
I was going to do it and and sometimes I
just like surprising her but when the
cameras were rolling so what's she gonna
do because she's got a same character
because she's a professional as an
actress like she's not gonna break so I
am yeah I did a few dodgy things to her
and hopefully she forgives me because at
the end of the day I love her she's
gorgeous I'm going to her Hollywood Walk
of Fame stuff yeah yeah so I'm going to
that tomorrow because I'm so pumped for
her she's just the best chick and doing
this movie with her which essentially is
like a to hand out it was just a dream
come true
and one last question at the trash bag
dress is my favorite
tell me about it I almost want the trash
bag dressed tonight I wear these custom
Christopher Kane dress it's you know it
steps it up a little bit in the from the
trash bag dress but that was my own
dress that I that I wore and I thought I
know this joke would be good for the
media and it's and it's right up top in
the film and against such a huge love
yeah thank you so much and a big shout
out to all the mothers out there happy
Mother's Day and come to cities movie
with your family or just by yourself
I enjoy it okay this one's just a huge
fun one
men always underestimate us
and that is what we use
[Music]